we have a voicemail number that you can
call
absolutely anytime you want the number
is 219
to david p here's a question about our
old friend
rudy giuliani take a listen to this
hi this is jim from canada yeah and uh
i was wondering i was watching one of
your old episodes about rudy giuliani
right now uh back a year ago i was
wondering have you heard what's happened
to him lately
i mean last time i heard about a couple
of months ago
he was facing the possibility of uh
being debarred or whatever
from uh you know from a legal practice
yeah
he was going to have his lawyer's
license uh revoked
or taken away i'm just curious uh any
news about
uh rudy lately just curious
have a good day keep up the good work so
there actually there is rudy news
first of all over the last couple days
news broke
that uh rudy giuliani this is amazing
rudy giuliani tried to get
actor sasha baron cohen arrested for
extortion
over the entire borat 2 fiasco
with maria bakalova that we now know
about
um rudy was suspended from youtube over
election fraud or fraud uh he may be
back on youtube now i'm not i'm not
totally sure but at one point he was
suspended and i actually
saw clips during that suspension of rudy
uh i i guess the clips must have been on
some other platform not youtube
rudy still talking as recently as about
seven to ten days ago
about the election being uh stolen from
him
by uh by joe biden stolen from trump
by joe biden and there is reportedly
a criminal investigation um
going on into rudy giuliani so that's
the latest with rudy giuliani
on today's bonus show we are going to
talk about
miami beach declaring a state of
emergency
over the absolute insanity of spring
break
crowds that have flocked there because
it's been
promoted as just being wide open it's
covered freedom
as uh framed by many and we're going to
talk about this on the bonus show and
it's particularly funny because
as many of you know we're going to be on
the show's taking a week off
next week and um i was actually
being fully vaccinated myself i was
actually thinking
with my girlfriend of driving to a beach
somewhere
and you know maybe south carolina but
south carolina's not really that warm
yet
in uh in march maybe florida i love
miami beach and then i saw
it's spring break hell it's coveted hell
it's absolutely nuts
so we decided to go some somewhere else
i am going to be going somewhere else
but it's going to be a place that
requires testing for example to go and
and this type of thing
and so i tweeted about this over the
weekend saying i'm really glad
i made the decision not to go there and
some blue check mark right winger i
didn't even know who who he was but
you can you'll find this if you look at
my twitter sort of like tweeted an
attack on me saying
you're vaccinated and you're still so
afraid of something that even for
unvaccinated people has like a 1
death rate that you're still not coming
down to florida and within
like minutes of that tweet florida
declared a state of
miami beach declared a state of
emergency and a curfew
so yes it's less about will i
as a vaccinated person get sick on the
beaches of miami
it's more about it doesn't sound fun i
don't want to go
and be in a curfew situation
with all sorts of unvaccinated untested
people going completely crazy now that
that's not interesting to me and i felt
like instantly vindicated by my choice
as miami beach is now in a state of
emergency we will talk about that on the
bonus show that's a big lead up
we also will talk about the biden white
house staff
cannabis policy which just led to
some people being let go and we will
have more about this entire putin biden
debate idea with biden calling putin a
killer
and the coverage that it's received we
will also talk about that
and more on today's bonus show how do
you get access to the bonus show
um it's very easy you sign up at
joinpakman.com that's it
we have an unpublished new secret coupon
code i'm telling you but no one else
that code is immoral 21 all one word all
lower case
it's an immorally cheap discount i might
regret it
a year from now i might look back and
say that was disgusting when i offered
that coupon code
you can also simply become a patron on
patreon
at at least the five dollar a month
level
patreon.com davidpakmanshow all right
i'll see everybody on the bonus show
and then tomorrow we're here this week
we're off next week and then we'll be
back